so many different angles to look at this
story we've heard from Tyson Foods
talking about a major disruption to our
food supply possible meat shortage
you're looking at the crops angle the
vegetable the produce angle of all this
how has this pandemic affected our food
supply thanks for having me Sandra it's
been very very difficult we have in this
country highly efficient and very safe
food supply infrastructure those supply
chains have been well developed over the
years and when this shutdown happened it
literally blew them up we are trying to
repeat all of our supply chains to be
able to continue providing safe and
affordable and fresh food to consumers
through grocery outlets but the loss of
the retail or the restaurant sector
really threw a grenade in the middle of
our food supply chain so Dave you
Western growers supplies more than half
of the fruits and vegetables in the
United States
farmers your farmers are based in
California Arizona New Mexico and
Colorado so give us an example of how
you have had to just see some of that
food go to waste because essentially you
don't have an end destination for it
last week I was in the desert area of
California and Imperial County in the
southeast corner of the state as one of
my members plowed 350 acres of very high
quality romaine lettuce right back into
the ground there was literally no place
to put that product we've more than
doubled our donations to food banks in
California and still there is so much
fresh produce that of course is highly
perishable and doesn't have a market
because of the loss of the restaurant
and food service sector that these
farmers really have no choice they spend
about half of the total dollar
harvesting the crop if there's no place
to sell that crop you don't you can't
spend that money on harvest and you have
to put it back in the ground and it's
really tragic